Nicola Sturgeon warning that dropping
this stay-at-home message could be a
catastrophe if done too early do you
broadly agree with that but this is my
point it's addressed to both Boris
Johnson and it's addressed to Nicola
Sturgeon whatever you do in the future
is dependent on whether you have got
some protection for people and that
means you've got a test and my complaint
is in Scotland as in the UK only one and
a half percent of the population have
been tested for this virus that it's
difficult to end the lockdown but it's
also difficult to give people
reassurance and it's going to be
difficult to get the rate of infection
down unless you could assure yourself
that people have been tested and are not
carrying the virus and both the Scottish
government and the UK government are
failing to do this and it's become so
obvious to me because I I haven't wanted
to speak out in criticism I've wanted
always to be constructive but if you
have all people's forms as we have in
Scotland and half the deaths are coming
out of old people's homes and in half
the old people's homes and more there
are people with this disease if you
don't test people until after you've got
a case then you are simply trying to
solve a problem after it has been
created you've got to have proactive
testing it's got to be preventative
testing it's got to be regular and
routine and to be fair to every care
worker and to be every resident to be
fair to them and also to be fair to
people in the health service we should
have routine testing and before Boris
Johnson makes more announcements and
before Nicola Sturgeon does anything
else she should address and he should
address the failure to test enough
people so that we cannot be sure who has
the disease and we cannot be sure
because symptoms are being carried that
are not obvious to people and people are
infecting people without us knowing it
right so just to be clear you're saying
not enough testing yet for Boris Johnson
to ease the lockdown at all either even
slightly I think both of them have got
to address this problem that you cannot
reassure the public you're asking people
at some point to go out and make contact
with other people but you're also trying
to get the rate of infection down if
you're not testing
efficiently and remember the chief
medical officer and the chief scientific
officer admitted that not enough testing
had been done at beginning as I say I
haven't wanted to come in on this but
when I see that only one and a half
percent of the British population are
being tested then even at the best Boris
Johnson's two hundred thousand figure a
day would be testing only not 0.3
percent of the population in Scotland
the figure is actually less ambitious
than Boris Johnson's new figure it's
just not good enough the only way when
you don't have a vaccination if there
was a vaccination you'd tell everybody
to get vaccinated in the absence of a
vaccine you've got to test and you've
got to find out who is carrying this
disease and how you can isolate them
quickly from the rest of the public but
of course if people are going to if
people are staying at home and don't
have the disease then you can actually
test them and they could get back to
work right but I mean if you believe the
papers here like headlines like happy
Monday and you know that a sense that
there is gonna be a slight easing even
from Monday all the of the lock down do
you think that you think that could be a
reckless way to start things did but
mark you're getting obsessed about a
story that is not even been announced
yet it's all speculation I don't think
Boris Johnson can make an announcement
on Sunday in the way that these papers
are saying so without ramping up testing
massively so let's concentrate on the
problem rather than on headlines that
actually mean very little until we see
the results and everybody's reacting to
stories that are speculation what you've
got to do is deal with the real problem
people are dying in all people's homes
and people are dying elsewhere and one
of the reasons they're dying is the
failure to test it's both wrong and it's
tragic and I feel sorry for health
workers who are being dragged into
situations where they are trying to do
their best to save lives and putting
their lives at risk
because we haven't tested them I talked
to one of the heads of an old people's
home in Scotland today who runs actually
15 homes and he told me that he had
1,100 staff and he'd only been able to
get 162 tested he had 700 there patients
and only 192 had being tested and this
in a situation where everybody is saying
that
at the epicenter of the crisis he told
me about people who were carrying
symptoms and he had not been able to get
them tested that this is something that
could be dealt with today and tomorrow
and the report that we put out today
from our Scottish future says what can
be done what you do is you ramp up your
manufacturing capacity just as if you
were it was a wartime effort you ramp up
your manufacturing country we figure
companies that are necessary to produce
the testing equipment then what you do
is of course you have centers all over
the country far more than we've got at
the moment mobile testing home testing
workplace testing you get it done and
then the next thing to do is you get the
laboratory capacity properly used and of
course there are spaces that are not
being used at the moment that could
actually be brought into use now if you
had a wartime mobilization strategy that
was dealing with this then you could
ramp up the number of tests by hundreds
of thousands every day and that in my
view and the absence of a vaccination is
going to become essential and anybody
who wants to talk about the next few
days has got to talk and explain why if
they're going to make changes or if
they're not going to make changes in the
niccola sturgeons case they have failed
on testing and they continue to fail on
that front okay you're a former
Chancellor you know better than I do
that business is gonna be crying out to
get back to work particularly the Bank
of England's warning about the sharpest
recession on record there is this
argument that we just simply need to get
businesses back operating look the
economy exists for people people don't
exist for the economy we know that you
cannot solve this economic emergency
unless you start to solve the medical
emergency we know that unless you can
actually get people properly protected
against this virus you cannot get
everybody in the way that you want back
to work so let's deal with the health
emergency let's get it sorted why is it
after three months that ninety eight and
a half percent of the population have
not being tested if this was a
vaccination you would be demanding a
hundred percent vaccination coverage by
now why when in the absence of a
vaccination we're relying on testing to
know how we can avoid people being in
contact with the disease we don't
the testing and the contract tracing
then the isolation of course we need the
hand-washing and of course we also need
the social distancing but there's a
missing element in this that you can't
sort the economic problem unless you've
got some progress on the health problem
that is good enough to be able to give
people confidence that they can come
into contact with other people but isn't
the point here that the casualties of a
prolonged shutdown could be every bit as
as bad as the casualties from from the
virus in the in the circumstances were
in well are you wanting to put lives
second to livelihoods you cannot do that
to mark you've got to deal with the
health emergency and really I've had to
enter this debate because people are
talking in abstract terms about the next
year a few a few weeks and there's all
these headlines today but the reality is
when you look at the figures about
what's actually happening on the ground
we are leaving people far too vulnerable
and we've got to do something about it
now I've got plenty ideas about how we
can bring the economy back and I know
from my own experience in 2008/9 you
will have to do it without causing the
levels of unemployment that people are
predicting the levels of bankruptcies
they're inevitable if we do what he's
being proposed at the moment the levels
of mortgage repossessions that we saw in
the 80s and the 90s but we avoided in
2009-10 now there's plenty of ways that
we can plan to do this and do it
purposefully but you cannot do it
successfully
unless you've dealt with the medical
problem but are you do you agree that
the way Russia sunic is handling with it
handling this is broadly right that they
are throwing money at it well I was the
one who said look in his first set of
proposals he had missed out employment
and then of course he did the right
thing and he guaranteed that people's
employment would be safeguarded
but that's only stage one of the crisis
look stage two is dealing with what
happens when the employment subsidy is
starting to either run out or it's
removed altogether and when the banks
are calling in the loans that have been
given because it's only loans in the
main there are some grants but mainly
loans that have been given to companies
now we've got to deal with a situation
where unless there is a second phase of
gotten an action unless they are cordon
the way they approach the recovery then
large numbers of businesses that may be
viable over the next year but can't
create sufficient revenues over the next
three months will be brought down either
by the banks or by the Inland Revenue
who are the fat authorities unless we
were able to do something to help them
so yes we need an economic plan the easy
part in a sense economically has been
done you hand out money you you say to
people we can reassure you for the next
three months but the difficult part as
the Bank of England would I think
emphasize is you've got to have a plan
to keep unemployment low and you've got
have a plan to stop business
bankruptcies and I think I know that
there are ways that we can do this but
first of all you have got to sort out
the medical emergency yeah just a couple
more I mean broadly speaking obviously
it's a crisis of huge challenges for any
government what do you make broadly of
the way this is being handled given the
trajectory that we're on well I want the
government to succeed in this and the
whole country wants the government to
succeed I want the UK government and the
Scottish government to secede that's why
I want to be constructive and not
critical and I obviously want to look
forward with proposals that I'm making
today and not look back but unless the
government listens to the proposals that
we are making about testing and unless
they match that to the contract tracing
and to the isolation policies and put
that complimentary to social distancing
and the way they move that forward we
will still have both the medical and the
economic problem some months from now I
want to avoid a second wave and a second
peak but the waiter avoided as you are
trying to come out of your first peak is
is in my view and I come back to it
because we have looked at studies that
have been done in America and elsewhere
studies that are being done in Europe
and we have been let's be honest we have
been testing about half the population
as a percentage that the countries that
have been more successful Germany Norway
Denmark Korea and we mean half as
successful as doing that testing as
these other countries and we've got to
learn some of the lessons from what has
been more successful than what has
happened in this country so I don't want
to be critical but I want to put forward
constructive proposals of
what can be done and I don't think
anybody should be in any doubt today
that you cannot avoid a second peak
unless you do more about testing okay
and just finally you made great play
early on in this crisis of global
cooperation isn't the truth that it's
basically every country for itself and
there's precious little global
cooperation well if we're going to get
out of this and eradicate this disease
an entirety we're going to need global
cooperation because unless the vaccine
is in every country it's not going to
make us altogether safe and unless we
build up capacity to deal with these
problems in the poorest countries
they're going to come back to haunt us
in the richest countries I've been
disappointed by the level of global
cooperation there was a pledging
conference but I was pleased that Boris
Johnson was part of that on Monday to
raise money for the vaccine and to build
up the capacity in our health care
system and globally but certainly more
has got to be done and we must not
retreat into this America first China
first India first Russia first the sort
of approaches that have been taken for
too long the evidence is that if one
area merits multilateral cooperation and
has got to can only work with
multilateral cooperation it's dealing
with a pandemic